hello everyone my name is Michael Volos
I'm the founder and Trader of orderflows
decom and I'm pleased to present my
newest presentation on the volto
indicators orderflow analysis without
having to read an orderflow chart so let
me ask you does orderflow analysis
confuse you this is an orderflows chart
you there's a lot of numbers uh a lot of
red and green sometimes you get
blue you know a lot of boxes just a lot
of numbers and for some people it's a
bit confusing honestly you know if there
was a way you can take your analysis
from an orderflows chart and put it on a
normal bar chart would that be of value
to you so who am I and why you should
listen to
me my name is Michael BOS and you know
I've been an Institutional Futures
Trader for about 20 years you know I
spent eight years at JP Morgan four
years at Cargill three years at CER Bank
you know these are Big names these are
Big trading firms you know it's it's not
like I just graduated college and I
started trading Forex in my dorm room
you know with a micro account of $50 and
all of a sudden I think I'm the world's
greatest Trader you know this is what I
did for my living this is how I put food
on the table and a roof over my
head so for over 20 years I have traded
at the institutional level and studied
virtually every Futures market and made
thousands upon thousands of Trades do I
think I found the Holy Grail when it
comes to trading no of course not but
what I can say is I'm confident that the
trading strategies that I've developed
are among the best you will find in
today's market first a brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains potential risk
and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results okay orderflow analysis is being
pushed on the trading public as if it's
the next great thing but actually
orderflow has been around for a long
long time it's just that without
computers has been difficult for many
traders to understand what is going on
in the order flow let alone understand
how to read it you know some people will
have you believe that it's possible to
find opportunities in trading which are
no risk this is every Trader's quest in
fact a lot of Traders enter to the
market thinking their trading will have
no risk at all or at the very least very
little risk that is their downfall
for the last several years I've been
teaching Traders how to read and apply
orderflow in their trading however I've
noticed some Traders took order flow
While others just couldn't wrap their
head around it as a result I developed
three powerful orderflow indicators to
help Traders use orderflow analysis in
their trading without having to work
through an orderflow chart again this is
an orderflow chart this is in the e-
minis and you know for me I've been
trading with orderflow for you know most
of my career
and in depth for at least the last 10
years once you know the information was
really put in a easy to read format but
as you can see you know for the
untrained eye there's a lot of
numbers a lot of boxes a lot of red a
lot of green a lot of blue if you don't
know what you're looking for then what's
the point so what I did what my goal was
was to take my analysis I could look at
this chart and see you know what there's
a nice buying opportunity in here and
what I did is
I wrote down my steps you know my
analysis gave it to my programmer and
had them put it into you know a code
that can just mark on a normal bar chart
where you should be buying right here
you got the blue arrow so it takes all
this information in here puts it
analyzes it and just plots it on the
chart say hey idiot you know this is
where you should be buying you know I
say hey idiot you know no offense to you
it's more on on me you know when you're
looking at an orderflow chart there's
just so much information and sometimes
you're going to miss things I miss
things sometimes you know I've got many
different ways of analyzing orderflow
and sometimes you know I need a whack in
the side of the head saying hey idiot
don't miss
this so you can see there's you know
this is a nice
move so I've taken my three best
orderflow tools and had them programmed
into ninja Trader so that they'll work
on a normal bar chart so there no more
trying to make heads or tails out of an
orderflow chart you can use your
existing chart it runs on ninja Trader
ninja Trader you can download for free
they have a free version a paid version
it will run on the free
version the paid version is if if you
want to route your orders through ninja
Trader brokerage or one of their
approved
Brokers and I'll be honest with you I
love orderflow analysis that's the
foundation of my trading for nearly 20
years but I realize orderflow is not for
everyone that's why I created this
orderflows BOS indicator Suite
imagine having the power of orderflow
analysis without having to deal with
reading the footprint chart well now you
can again the footprint chart okay you
know there's a lot of stuff in here to
digest you know you got this is this
green line is the high of the day you
hit the high you start to come off well
you know should you be buying it or
should you be selling are we going to go
back up make another new high like you
did here or we going to hit this high
and we're going to sell off and here you
get the indication right here with this
this red arrow and again another nice a
nice fivepoint sell off from the high
you know anytime you hit a high or you
hit a low you want to know are you going
to bounce and then retest that higher
low or are you going to you know go in
the opposite direction That's The Power
of order flow order flow will help you
make that
decision so what is the orderflows Volos
indicator sweet well there's three
indicators there's the Volos flip the
Volos transition the Volos U-turn and
each indicator reads a different aspect
of order flow
so you know honestly I I think the I I
say the the BOS flip is more for very
short-term trading although you know you
could write it out you can get some nice
big moves transition is sort of
medium-term you know uh scalping to
short-term trading Volos U-turn is is I
think a little bit more on the shortterm
to I don't want to say swing trading but
you know you can catch moves from the
high to the low with
it okay so the BOS flip reads sudden
abrupt changes in the buying and selling
which often precede explosive moves I
think it's ideal for scalping and
short-term trading here's some
examples you know when I say short-term
trading you know I I mean over the next
you know uh depends on you know say
you're using a minute chart you know the
next 10 minutes 15 minutes you know if
you're trading a minute chart and you're
holding the position for two hours you
shouldn't be trading a minute chart you
should be on on a longer time frame and
you this is a five range chart mini
NASDAQ andq and you can see you know
this one you know this sell didn't work
this buy it kind of worked tested the
low before it pop back up the sale the
sell failed the sell worked this was a
nice big sell right down to a buy
here this is a mini da again a five
range chart you know one signal right
here at this high and it traded from you
know
18 I'll call it 18 315 down to 18 you
know below 1800 18270
18280 a mini da this time it's it's a 10
range chart and and you know you got
your your low here swing low and it
makes a nice move up you again it's from
17 you know what you want to call it
17880 sorry 17 uh oop sorry 890 rather
all the way you know above 1,800 18,000
rather um you know this a nice move and
you got another confirmation here you
know say you you just caught this move
and you got out well you got another Buy
Signal here for the next leg up
the B's transition reads uh when the
market is potentially changing from a
demand driven Market to a supply driven
Market or vice versa again I think this
indicator is designed more for
short-term trading you know by
shortterm you know people get lost
sometimes when they're trading you know
they've got a position obviously you
want to let it ride as long as you can
but you also have
to be smart about it you know don't let
it ride to Infinity you know when I
started
trading many many many years ago I'll
say many years ago was about uh you know
the 19 early
1990s you know people what's your profit
Target Infinity you know I would be
buying um the Deutch Mark SS Frank you
know 10 15 minutes after the open
thinking I'm going to hold it all the
way to the close you know the days that
you had the big range yeah I I I'd make
a lot of money but you know there's
times where you know You' go up most of
the morning then lunchtime it would turn
around and you know instead of booking a
nice profit you know I had either a
small loss Break Even or small profit so
you know when you're trading you have to
think about your time frame again you
know I see a lot of people you know they
they I I have indicators that you can
download for free on on my website and
you know one guy messaged back oh this
is crap you I I tried it on four range
charts and you know every trade I took
was was a loser yeah but then when I try
to ask them you know how are you looking
at the market you know he never replied
but you know so I've been running four
minute four range charts for you know
how many months already since then and
you know I the indicator you know it
works and I know people are making money
with it and you know I don't understand
his trading you know maybe he's he's
thinking he's just going to take it for
10 you know S&P is for 10 points on a
four range chart you know if you get 10
points on a four range chart fantastic
you know but if you're looking at a four
range chart you shouldn't be looking at
a profit Target of of of 10 points you
you should have a smaller uh profit
Target so I say short-term trading know
I mean anywhere between you know the the
next couple of bars
to you know 15 20 bars out you know
beyond that I I think you're really
pushing the envelope I mean that's just
me that's my opinion on on how you
should approach um the time frames in
your trading but you should be cognizant
of the time that you're in a
trade so how does the transition work
well again it's looking for areas where
you know the a supply driven Market is
changing into a demand driven Market or
the opposite demand driven Market
becomes a supply driven market and you
know what that means is you know when
when there's a supply driven Market that
means the Market's going lower there's a
lot of Supply when it's a demand driven
Market the Market's going higher there's
a lot of demand everyone's coming in and
buying so what it's going to look for
it's going to look for these changes you
here you we went up started coming off
you know Supply in the market then boom
you get a little demand and you see it
pop back up but then here you get supply
again coming in and you get a nice
little move lower now you know people
will say well you know here it gave you
a short here but then you know back here
it's it stopped you out well I mean come
on it's a 5 minute chart you're going to
hold it for um you know 510 15 20 25 30
3540 4550 you know two hours I I I don't
think you can do
that and and here's a bonds a five
minute chart and you get the swing low I
mean look at it's got a nice move up
there again bonds you make this move up
boom you get the signal it goes down
here this one kind of goes sideways
before it goes up against
you the Volus U-turn reads the price
action in the order flow and looks for
the points where buyers and sellers have
given up and the market has a tendency
to reverse the
indicator I think is best use for
shortterm and swing Traders but again
you know you could use it if you're
scalping if you're trading on a dome and
you're looking for a level again what
this U-turn does it it finds these areas
where there's hidden support or hidden
resist resistance that again doesn't
show up in a normal bar chart and how
does it look this is how it looks this
is a a mini
Dow ym uh one minute chart you got your
swing High here and it sells off you
know you got your little pop up here and
go sideways you know then a couple sells
here and we come off a little bit I
don't want you thinking that every trade
is going to be like this you know you're
going to get some or just go sideways on
you um that's how trading is you know
the could be a big shift in supply and
demand but then all of a sudden someone
else comes in you know say big demand
but then you know some big commercial
comes in with with a lot of supply and
hits the market it can just change you
know instantly like that don't think
that you know the market is static it's
Dynamic it's always changing people are
always coming in reacting to what price
is
doing it's crude oil eight
range you got this low here and you know
pops up and sort of goes sideways pops
back you know before it uh makes a move
back up again
crude 8 range again you know here you
got your demand driving the market
higher higher then boom you it's telling
you hey there's an area up here there's
a lot of supplies coming to the market
has hit the market it could be ripe for
a selloff and what does it do you know
it goes sideways and then Falls
over you know what you would like
obviously is to have you know every
trade work out like this or you know
every trade instantly after you buy just
goes straight up but sometimes you know
you buy and the market just sort of
spins its Wheels a little bit before
falling off you know maybe people the
demand is not yet satisfied and you know
the sellers till they selling you know
offering the supply then finally the
seller takes over and the supply just
really overwhelms the buyers because you
know there if there's nobody left to buy
what's going to happen when there's LW
Supply the Market's going to drop and
you know and and it drops off here from
what is that 50 5090 down to 5030
so you got ask yourself how do you want
to trade the hard way or the easy
way the hard way well I'll say the hard
way I mean for me it's easy but for some
people this is hard and you know I
completely understand that I get it you
know it's confusing especially you know
when you've never looked at it again you
just see a lot of numbers a lot of boxes
you don't know what the heck is going on
that's fine there's no shame in that you
know I I don't understand Greek doesn't
mean that it's not a good language right
I mean you know there's things that
people just don't understand and
probably never
understand but you know if you could
take that information that you're seeing
in this chart in here and pop it into a
nice bar chart get the signal hey then
you know you're you're using the power
of computers you know what they've been
invented for to make your life
easier that's going to help you trading
you know yeah it makes your life easier
it puts it in this format but again if
if you don't know what you're looking at
then your life is confused again but if
you take it a step further and take your
analysis and put it in a nice normal bar
chart like this then that's
great so remember you know orderflow
analysis is a tool but don't let
yourself miss out on its usefulness
because you don't understand it now you
can add it to your trading
Arsenal I call it the orderflows Volos
indicator sweet so now you can harness
the power of orderflow without having to
read an order flow chart because the
important information is plotted on your
chart one of the main reasons orderflow
Traders barely share their knowledge
with most other Traders is because it's
hard work and most people will not be
able to do it and honestly it's
frustrating at times and it's precisely
that most people can't do it then will
continue to work and after all if
everybody could do it then everybody
would make money and we know that's just
not
logical that's what makes order flow so
powerful is that the overwhelming
majority do not know how to use it let
alone apply each other trading and take
it a step further there's not many
people even know that it exists this
information but it's all out there in
the open it's it's there for your
interpretation and use it in your
trading you know it'd be
like learning to fly flying an airplane
but without all the gauges you know can
can you do it yeah of course you can but
you know it'll make your your flying a
lot easier if you have alterate you know
all the all the little gauges that that
tell you you know how high you are and
how much fuel you have left you know
it's information like that that's useful
to you and it's available to you so you
should use it so you know in trading as
in life only a few people are truly
winners and the rest are losers or break
even at best successful Traders are the
minority you should always be trying to
avoid being part of the majority if you
want to come out a winner you know if
the majority is is losing don't do what
the majority of people are doing you
know change it
up now I said there's three indicators
there's the clip there's the transition
there's the U-turn
and you can put them on chart separately
or you could put them all on the same
chart now if you put them all on the
same chart maybe you want to change what
they look like you know this is a chart
I have all three indicators on there
they're all giving this the same you
know triangle up or triangle down red
for sell blue for buy I mean you could
change it you could adjust the size
however you want to do it it's all
customizable but you know I just want to
show you you know when you put all three
together how it looks now you know
sometimes you're going to get signals
that that don't work you know say you're
just using one indicator and you get you
know you hit a bad streak you know with
with three losers in a row well if
you're you're adding a different
indicator in there you know maybe
instead of three or four losers in a row
you get two losers a winner a winner two
losers so you know it's it's helping
your your training percentage a bit you
know as opposed to sitting through three
losers in in a row nobody likes to have
losers let alone three in a row if you
have three in a row you start
questioning you know the meaning of life
but you know if you could break it up
sometimes it's going to make your
trading less stressful which is you know
what you want to do in trading so here
you know this is all three of them you
got a buy Here a buy Here a sell which
didn't work out came right back with
another buy that worked out a buy
another buy another sell you know it's
picking almost every I say every turning
point but it's picking turning points as
you can see and that's what you want to
do
or you know confirmation say you know
you got a sell right up here you start
going down should I take profit will you
get you know maybe you take profit then
you get another sell here you know
confirmation that you should still be
short so you get short again okay so you
you're getting short short short you're
still short you get a buy here okay
maybe I should cover okay well you cover
then it just heads lower eh okay you're
kicking yourself you get a buy here okay
maybe I should buy then it comes right
back with a
cell and it continues
down again these are the three indic s
working together on the same
chart this is a euro currency it's a one
minute chart and you see you know this
one didn't work out this one didn't work
out but then you know you got one that
did you know people say oh you got two
losers in a row this sucks you know I
want something that gives me 80% 90%
winners I mean come on be realistic if
you could get you know something above
50% then that's great you know cuz not
every winner you know everyone says oh
you have to have 3 to one
reward to risk I mean you know people
that say that you know they're just
theorists they they don't actually trade
you know there's going to be times when
you're just happy to get a tick out of a
trade you know instead of getting five
points out of the snps you're just happy
to get a tick out of it you know it's
it's like Tiger Woods in golfing you
know sometimes he Shanks the t- shot but
then he makes a recovery you know and
makes par you know he's happy at that
you know it's not like oh I got to get a
a birdie on every hole yeah you would
like to you know or an eagle on every
hole you would like to but you know the
it is there sometimes you're going to
you know shank your te- shot off and you
you're going to be playing recovery and
you know trading is very similar to that
you I'll say okay loser loser and then
you got a nice winner another nice
winner you know that's what trading is
sometimes you know you shank your t-
shot off with a couple bad trades and
then you get the nice recovery there you
know don't think you can make everything
back in one trade you know it's a
process you know I'll say it's a numbers
game but it's a process you know you you
have a loss okay start thinking how you
can recover it back in the next trade in
the next
trade again this is all three here um so
you get this buy here it didn't really
work out but then boom you get the sell
right after that yeah it's a nice sell
down you get this low here it picks the
low you know comes back up sell didn't
work sell yeah maybe not maybe got
stopped out on the second one then again
some more Buys so you know what you're
getting this this nice move down this
nice move up this nice move up
crude oil so minute chart you know this
one didn't work out one sideways and
then boom you get the sell you know
comes right down into this low this low
probably would have stopped you off but
then this one saying hey you know this
is the low don't miss it and you know it
goes sideways before it makes the move
up and you know these don't really work
out this one does you know are you
risking to are you willing to risk a
couple little losses like this to catch
this move you know you should be you
know but everyone thinks they just look
at this and say oh you know I suffered
losses you know then they don't take
into effect that oh you know they could
have had this loss this winner here or
this winner here you know it's some for
a lot of people you know maybe they're
they're not properly um funded you know
margined you know they they you know if
they're trading e minis they got an
account with um you know $5,000 and
they're trading 10 Lots you know you got
5,000 in your account maybe you should
be trading two lots not uh fully maxed
out that you know you have a loss like
this that you know it sort of um
handicaps you
again NASDAQ you know this one a little
bit work you know this one kind of works
out works out works out then boom you
know if you again say you know you you
took a little bit of a profit here then
he gives you another buy here right
before it shoots up like this get a sell
here it comes down but then you get
another buy here and it shoots up again
you know that's that's the beauty of
mixing a couple of these these three
indicators together is because you know
there's going to be times like I said
you know you're going to get you know
maybe you know a couple little losses
dings like this but you know what you
want to catch this you want to catch
that so you know whether you're a
scalper a short-term Trader swing Trader
I got you covered you know these
indicators are my private indicators
that I've released to a limited FL few
traders in my inner circle you know my
inner circle is a closed group of
traders that I work
with and it's not open to the public
it's just you know it's people that have
shown to me that they really want to you
know know orderflow and learn orderflow
but you know what a lot of people have
asked me about my in circle and you know
I don't want to take too many people in
but um you know I've decided to release
do a limited release to the trading
public of these
indicators the indicators run on ninja
Trader 7 they're currently get imported
in the next two weeks this is uh January
21st right
now so hopefully by the end of the month
they'll be available for nt8 and when
you buy the indicat package you'll get
the upgrade to nt8 is for free as soon
as is available I'm still on
nt7 um I haven't made my own personal
migration to nt8
nt8 yet but you know I'm hoping to do it
in the next few weeks so why am I
offering these indicators as such a
great deal well I want traders to be
able to take advantage using orderflow
in their trading I do a lot of training
of Traders yet many just can't wrap
their head around order flow and with
this package of orderflow indicators I
think it will enable a lot of traders to
profit from
orderflow so go here www. orderflows
docomo HTML again you know I I named
these after myself because a lot of my
indicators that I had released you know
over the last couple years have been
copied by other people and they're
they're calling it all the ratio algo or
algo this or algo that because algo is a
buzzword that you know attracts Traders
you know new Traders thinking oh you
know I got to have the latest algo
busting indicator well it's just all
you know what it is it's just
simple orderflow analysis um programmed
into the computer to make it your life
easier you know again if you don't want
order flow you can you can look for
these things yourself honestly but you
know it takes Year I'll say I hate
reading you have to have 10,000 hours of
screen time I think that's just
you have to apply yourself and think
properly you know I know people that
have come in and started trading and
within 3 months bang you know it made
perfect sense they didn't have 10,000
hours of screen time you know there
there's certain people that take to it
there's certain people that don't take
to it and this is designed for the
people that you know it's a little bit
slower that it just doesn't come
instantly you know people could it's
like learning to play the violin some
people just take to it really quick
others you know struggle you know not
everybody is going to be playing at at
Carnegie Hall so again you know go to my
website orderflows docomo you can learn
more about the indicators there um I got
I got a big uh explanation more in depth
in this video so so thanks for watching
this and I hope to see you on the inside